vous susciter la tentation c'était la
tentation entre guillemets du crime
organisé ou des voleurs ou de gens qui
moi je soutiens les questions de
Guillaume parce que on vous exposant
comme ça je suis désolé vous prenez des
risques de mon point de vue inconsidéré
cher
excusez-moi à Dubaï non non pas de ça à
Dubaï vous vivez dans un environnement
hyper privilégié entre influenceurs dans
des endroits de luxe non non mais ça
c'est pas vrai
vous pouvez pas comparer vous louez à
Dubaï vous êtes propriétaire je loue et
je louais combien par mois combien par
mois
c'est pas le même monde c'est pas le
même monde que
en location bien sûr c'est exactement la
même manière
aujourd'hui est une scie potentielle et
doit quitter la France ou doit aller à
Duba sécurité